okay audi audi uh where are you from
originally where did you grow up
i growed up in indiana until i was eight
years old
and then my dad retired and moved back
to his
home place in leslie county kentucky
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents growing up as a kid
uh uptown was 12 year old 11 year old
then my mom and dad separated and who
raised you then
my dad and i stayed with my mom
sometimes but
not much because i started going down
the wrong path
what kind of stuff were you getting into
drugs
smoking weed and doing
field called sign x and uh percocet oh
really
yeah how old are you uh 46 year old or
46 in january so that was kind of the
beginning of the
the drug problem here in
appalachia how far did you go to school
eighth grade eighth grade and did you go
to work
at some point there oh yeah i worked out
my life
out of these hills i worked a few tax
paying jobs
but i dig roots called a yam
a cowos we call it rattleweed and a
stone root in the winter time now
and summer i dig ginseng and yellow root
and strip elm trees
on private property yeah people let's
just have them because they're no good
for
lumber you can't sell them up for lumber
but the bark is
the bark is valuable yeah and you you
see
like these gin saying you sell the
chinese uh well i sell them to a lot of
dealers here everyone pays the most you
know i still sell to
then that's what they do with it that's
a chinese
and that's where your most money is in
ginseng
and gallery
and this the life here in appalachia and
especially in the mountains is a
it's a tough life right it's a difficult
way to survive it's real tough
because the way i earn dig i'd have to
take a medic
and dig these out of the ground one by
one
and when they're just worth a couple
cents a route you know what
takes a lot of roots to make a hundred
dollars
that's a lot of digging that's two two
good sex
is a hundred dollars i'm talking about
sex like yes
you can imagine how many roots this
round would go into one second big
probably three four hundred roots if not
more
and that's three or four hundred times i
have to dig a hole down in the ground to
get it out
so it's rough yeah
do you love your life here in appalachia
i love it
what are your favorite things about it
the heels
is my number one favorite thing about it
and
being able to go in and out of them you
know when i want to
because they got diamond trails and
stuff we dig
roots off them too it's four wheeler
trails it goes from miles and miles
to these hills and
i ride my four wheeler longer and i'll
stop and
like a swag we call it a smile holler
go down in them look for roots you know
to me every day
i have to work just about every day to
survive
and you know i've done everything in the
world it's bad
i've sowed pills so pot but that's
all that's behind me i don't do that
crap no more
i just work for everything i get now
easy money is never good money
and what are the worst things about
living here what's the hardest part
just that you have to work so much
because there ain't no jobs you know no
good paying jobs
if you get a chair you have to have a
hustle you know like working out of the
hills or
you may work be a carpenter or something
i can't get out of jobs and just enough
to
feed yourself with is about how you make
i mean it's one of the poorest parts of
the country yeah and everyone
is going through the same a similar
struggle yeah is that what makes
everyone so helpful to each other
yeah somebody ain't got a place to stay
have took a menial person in my home
and then you you you didn't see my home
i got
a tiny home you see them tiny homes
likes on tv i see debt and i want
me and my wife to have one and that's
what i've done i'm still working on it
slowly but i'll get there as i get
the money you know most days let us make
30 40 dollars a day you know but
there's some days i can make a hundred
at the end of the week i guess it
averages up to a couple hundred dollars
to
250 a week if we have a decent week now
the bart pulling you can only do hit
three months every year
now that's real good money you can make
up for 500
a week but it's just for that short
period of time that still don't
help you the rest of the year and when
it's
20 degrees out and you have to get up at
5 30 in the morning it's still dark and
get on a cold
four four-wheeler atv you know that's
what we got to work on you can't get a
vehicle where we go
and it's rough you know
and i can't afford no side beside or i
could get something that had a little
heating
you know then so to heat your home you
use what
i use propane i can get a voucher down
here
that helps me out with it and at lkf
have you traveled have you been around
the country
uh yeah i've been to chicago
you know ohio nurse indiana and
just places like that you know
you ever consider leaving
yeah probably would if if i had a
vehicle
and could get insurance only yeah i'd go
to where where there was good jobs at
that way i know i'm making five or six a
week
my brother he made good money out of his
life and re
well he had a heart attack and acquitted
much older me just five years older but
the coal mines
i make an old man out of a young man you
know he gets old before his time
yeah i most definitely growed up hard
yeah do you have children no no kids no
no shooter but you did you yeah well
i've got stepchildren
yeah i've got a little step grandma i
play with almost every day
you know every day he comes out what do
you think about his future
if he stays here i i think he'll get a
you know my nephew's stuff there they
all got like
two maybe three college degrees
well one my one nephew does he's a
mortician than a
was a registered nurse national nurse
practitioner
but he stayed here uh yeah but
he might go to another county where
because the nurse right now
because that obamacare one reason
nurse's job is good to have right now
they give him like a
one place after them ten thousand bonus
to sign you know that's
his ten thousand and uh
signed with them for i guess so many
years and no sign of contract with him
that's me his best stopper at thirty
dollars there starting out
i just don't got the education for it i
was in special ed and never could learn
to read and write
so i had to get smart in other ways
street smart
do you consider yourself a hillbilly oh
yeah i'm hillbilly to the bone
all my people that did live in indiana
here's where they come from
you know it's leslie county and you're
proud of that yeah i'm proud of it yeah
and it's it's a because we he's just
like at hank williams junior sound
you know a country boy can't survive and
these country boys will
and can survive
and you're happy here oh i love it won't
be nowhere but the mountains
do you have any regrets no no
and you feel like you lived the life
that you wanted to yeah oh i've loved my
life
i love it because i met my wife that was
married to her
she passed away a year and a half ago
i'm sorry
and uh her name was rebel
gene khaled and that was the best thing
happened to me
or it helped get me out for drugs and
stuff well she did
yeah yeah you know
that's that's the reason i quit whisper
her because you know
i said it's my fault that she was on
them
because you know how you laugh if you're
doing something most time
in in here in this country part
they want to do it too yeah so you
started it you got her
yeah cows there to get started
but that ain't what killed her you know
what killed her she drunk bad water or
eat some type of bad meat and
give her a brain disease they said only
600 people
in the world got it you know around the
world most time it's not sure
it's in a foreign country or something
where they have to drink bad water
that's right uk hospital telling us that
anyway
that's what killed her yeah short killed
her i'm sorry
she was just as good as we are right now
and
five minutes later we had laid down she
tapped me on the shoulder and said her
right arm didn't move
and then from there she just got worser
every day
five weeks she was dead them spots and
moved to her motor skills and
parts of her brain i guess it worked her
motor skills
and she didn't have no control over her
arms or legs
they tried to give her medicine it
helped some kept her from her arms from
jerking and
her legs would just kick like that you
know
she was in bad shape i hated to see her
go like
that
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
don't do drugs that's a message i can
send
anybody there if they watch this don't
do drugs if you
just start and quit now because it
ruined your life i could have had
anything i wanted if i would have been a
drug addict
i lived in a brick home right now and
had no vehicle sitting in the yard
because i would have had a good job but
i wouldn't have been a drug addict
and i wasted a lot of money
i'm a little crippled up now from carp i
got three bad wrecks and
that last wreck wasn't long ago i
wrecked the four-wheeler and
broke my back both sides of my ribs and
uh
when i'd pee i peed that blood and i was
that's been right before i went cold
silver
you know was right that's what another
thing it made me go cold silver
i made three times i got in a real bad
accident
one of them killed a guy you know who
was driving us
killed him instantly my my first cousin
my dad's nephew and i said no more
and i i went to a detoxing hazard
for four days and then they put me in a
suboxone clinic
and it works if you do what they tell
you
it works you will get off drugs
and that's the message i got for young
people
don't do if you're fooling with them
right now
stop while you can you stop when you're
young when you get older it
it's real bad when you have to try to
quit them
it takes five times as long
all right audi well thank you so much
for sharing your story
and good luck with the with your your
your wife with you
your life from here thank you hope you
find a lot of roots in the in the hills
this week
this this winter oh oh i found them man
that old
dude named carbide we worked together
for the last 26 years
they have good friends here yeah yeah
i don't got a whole lot because a whole
lot of people's no good cheers and
some some people is people that's around
here
today it's good people yeah where i'm at
right now
the drugs that have kind of taken over
the younger generation yeah it's
throwing
younger and older people it's ruining
them too
yeah but the ones it's just starting
there's a good chance for them now and
the ones it's
for the young people they got a chance
to quit right now because they've not
done them that long if they are doing
them
and if they ain't doing them never touch
them because you'll be like me and have
nothing but a little tiny home to live
in
and uh for the older people there's help
for them too because i was one of the
worst
drug addicts in leslie county you were
yeah at one time one of the biggest
dealers
i let my mama step that cell for me and
they got busted
and they said it was the biggest to five
counties
i wasn't making a lot of money but i'll
never go back to that i want my money
the right way
you know i won't earn it
all right audi thank you so much for
sharing your story
you're welcome and good luck in the
mountains this winter okay
thank you
you